meta released a lot of models as open
source so uh the massively multi-lingual
speech model
that's I mean a lot I'll ask you
questions about this but the point is
uh you've open source quite a lot you've
been spearheading the open source
movement where's uh that's really
positive inspiring to see from one angle
from the research angle of course
there's folks who are really terrified
about the existential threat of
artificial intelligence and those folks
will say that you know
um you have to be careful about the open
sourcing uh step but where do you see
the future of Open Source here uh as
part of meta the tension here is do you
want to release the magic sauce that's
one
tension and the other one is uh do you
want to put a powerful tool in the hands
of uh Bad actors even though it probably
has a huge amount of positive impact
also
yeah I mean again
a stage that we're at in the development
of AI I don't think anyone looks at the
current state of things and thinks that
this is super intelligence
um and you know the models that we're
talking about for the Llama models here
are you know generally an order of
magnitude smaller than what open AI or
Google are doing so
I I think that at least for the stage
that we're in now the equities
balanced strongly in my view towards
doing this more openly
um I think if you got something that was
closer to Super intelligence then I
think you'd have to discuss that more
and and think through that
um a lot more and we haven't made a
decision yet as to what we would do if
we were in that position but I don't
think I think there's a good chance that
we're pretty far off from that position
so
um so
I I'm not
I'm certainly not saying that the
position that we're taking on this now
applies to every single thing that we
would ever do and you know certainly
inside the company and we probably do
more open source work than
you know most of the other big tech
companies but we also don't open source
everything and a lot of our the core
kind of app code for WhatsApp or
Instagram or something I mean we're not
open sourcing that it's not like a a
general enough piece of software that
would be useful for a lot of people to
do different things
um you know whereas
the software that we do whether it's
like an open source server design or
um or basically you know things like
memcache right like a good you know it
was probably our earliest project
um that I worked on it was probably one
of the last things that I that I coded
and and led directly for the company
um but but basically this like caching
tool
um for for quick data retrieval
um these are things that are just
broadly useful across like anything that
you want to build and and I think that
some of the
language models now have that feel as
well as some of the other things that
we're building like the translation tool
that that you just referenced so
text-to-speech and speech to text you've
expanded it from around 100 languages to
more than 1100 languages yeah and you
can identify more than the model can
identify more than
4 000 spoken languages which is 40 times
more than any known previous technology
to me that's really really really
exciting in terms of connecting the
world breaking down barriers that
language creates yeah I think being able
to translate between all of these
different
pieces in real time this has been a
kind of common
sci-fi idea that we'd all have you know
whether it's
on an earbud or glasses or something
that can help translate in real time
um between all these different languages
and that's one that I think technology
is basically delivering now so I think
yeah I think that's pretty pretty
exciting